I'm Franklin post we sang I'm an
architect and a landscape architect an
urban designer as a designer imposing my
vision on something they always come
from your origins your experiences in
life
intuition is part of this experience and
learning from experiences like this that
make a difference in what we do today
I guess the philosophy now that we have
is that all design must be integrative
so that you don't see where one stops in
the other starts and that for me is how
we should be always approaching our
projects Park Royal we were given the
building they already had an idea about
what they wanted to do obviously the
contribution was all that greenery and
that's a simple part the more difficult
part is to say can we add more texture
and so they're you know the gardens
those were given to us as just straight
balconies for planting it's really a
fully integrated building that blends
landscape and architecture together I
tell you one of the greatest advices
I've never forgotten was when I was
still in school at the the grad school
and I had an instructor called Yoshio
and Kitana gucci who himself is a very
good architect and I remember working
very hard on this project he looked at
it and we talked a little bit and then
he said so what I've never forgotten
that so every project that we take on
I'm looking for how can we make this
better how can this become much more
significant than what I see right now
because of two words so what that for me
is a seminal moment in my life the
marina barrage is there a special
project first thing we did was looked at
and said look this industrial building
is impossible to hide it's too big you
have to confront with parkland
you have you have no constraints in
terms of boundaries and land why don't
you cover the entire building with with
soil so that's what we did we told the
architect this is what you should do
winning the designer of the Year award
is a fantastic honor and then to be
honored in this way will continue to I
think spur on the younger ones to also
be as passionate as the ones who have
before and I have this thing for advice
is continue to stay really curious look
around don't get complacent just keep
pushing the limit